a Georgia congressional race that
Democrats tried to turn into a
referendum on President Trump is still
up for grabs this morning the two top
vote-getters Democrat John ausaf and
Republican Karen Handel will have a
runoff election in June all soft one
forty eight percent of the vote after
getting millions of dollars from
Democrats around the country president
Trump repeatedly tweeted against us off
yesterday he ended by calling the
outcome a big R win with runoff and
georgia glad to be of help the 11
Republican candidates combined got more
votes than all soft did but he told
supporters they had shattered
expectations Nancy Cordes is following
the special election in Georgia Nancy
good morning good morning Democrats were
hoping to use this race to show that
they are pushing back successfully on
Donald Trump and they threw everything
they had at it millions of dollars
armies of volunteers and while they
certainly got very close in this GOP
district they're going to have to settle
for that runoff in June y'all ready to
flip the 6th standing in front of an
energetic room of Democrats John ausaf
delivered what sounded like a victory
speech there is no doubt that this is
already a victory for the ages but the
30 year old documentary filmmaker and
former congressional aide failed to flip
the six Tuesday night he'll have another
shot in June we reject fear and
scapegoating and division that we choose
to love one another and to make things
happen and to win Georgia six districts
located in the suburbs north of Atlanta
is a GOP stronghold the seat has been in
Republican hand since 1979 held first by
Newt Gingrich for 20 years and then my
secretary of health and human services
Tom price for the last 11
Karen Handel is hoping to keep it that
way the former Georgia Secretary of
State escaped a crowded Republican field
and finished second to us off securing
her spot in the runoff president Trump
waited on the race on Twitter and in
robo calls if you don't vote tomorrow
aww Soph will raise your taxes destroy
your health care and flood our country
with illegal immigrants but last night
when she was asked about getting more
help from the president handle hesitated
he's a Republican president so of course
she want has a vested interest in making
sure that a Republican over to see
welcome to campaign for you well again
I'm gonna figure all that out tomorrow
the vote both sides are declaring
victory this morning Democrats say they
nearly nabbed what should be a safe GOP
seat while Republicans point out that
they held off a soft despite his 8
million dollar warchest forcing him into
a runoff now where he won't have the
benefit Gail of eleven Republican
candidates all splitting the Republican
vote all right to be continued for sure
Thank You Nancy